vous avez hésité avant d'accepter j'ai
pas hésité très longtemps parce que
j'ai vu qu'il y avait quelque chose à
faire j'ai vu que le contact était bon
contrairement à toutes les idées qu'on
avait pu se faire c'est quelqu'un qui
est très humain et c'est quelqu'un avec
lequel on peut construire quelque
difficiles en attendant de vous entendre
dire que c'est quelqu'un de très humain
moi je suis contre les idées qui
viennent dire qu'une personne est à
exclure de l'humanité que c'est un
monstre que c'est quelqu'un d'inhumain
bon je pense que les faits qui lui sont
reprochés sont au contraire très humain
et que ça amène peut-être allez
comprendre 6 alors grand palais de paris
on aura mathieu mais même ce qu'on
considère comme des monstres ou des gens
dehors de notre humanité doivent être
défendus et ont désormais d'acide êtres
humains c'est ça qu'elle veut lire ce
sont des états
il l'a contacté il est à fleury elle a
accepté de le défendre parce que le
droit français s'enorgueillit et moi
aussi que tout le monde savait que
défendue mme coutton en tant
qu'avocate elle considère qu'il est
humain il a une part d'humanité en lui
et heureusement qu'elle a discerné cette
part d'humanité donc je ne suis pas
choqué par ses propos mais pas une part
d'humanité sur un plateau télé dans une
plaidoirie dans un prétoire lors de
voilà de leurs deux à la cour tu vois
mais pas sur un plateau télé c'est
obscène en a pas envie d'entendre
l'humanité de tel ou tel moi j'ai pas
envie d'entendre l'humanité de fournir
et sur un plateau avec un avocat kenyan
vraiment fait pour lire et il était
quand même un peu humain mais taga en
fait fait ça dans ton travail n'est pas
sur un plateau télé passer un message
oral du mal est dans son rôle
j'ai pu me rebeller russe sur son rôle
d'avocate c'est de défendre y compris
l'indéfendable non et elle le sait
qu'elle défend l'indéfendable mais si
elle vient sur le plateau en disant mon
client est une ordure et il ya mais
aucune once du mc el eulma me sortir
elle fait pas son boulot et donc
effectivement c'est une parole qui est
inaudible et mais c'est parce qu'elle se
doit porter non je suis désolé repart
dont j'avais une famille que ça les
avocats c'est moi que la pire des
ordures soient défendus c'est tout à
fait normal à l'époque on tombait sur
maître vergès
c'est normal en revanche derrière pour
un cas comme ça le rôle d'un avocat
c'est de dire il a fauté fabas il a fait
un énorme crime à ce que souhaitait mais
là la phrase est horrible dira el adli
main sur quelqu'un qui a tué comme ça ça
veut dire qu'elle prend parti non melman
et que tout d'un coup il ya même une
attache à son client aurait doit juger
les faits est pire que ça non c'est
parce que j'ai avec la mission n'est pas
totalement en direct mais il ya quelques
minutes je ne comprends pas voilà que
tf1 et lci gueugnon à couper cette
phrase je suis pas d'accord non
pas légion et où il faut pas blesser les
gens
oui mais je te dis moi ça ferait non ils
peuvent pas couper sa part en différé
leur bave ils peuvent pas couper sa
correspondance qu'elle a dit oui mais tu
peux pas couper ça parce que c'est le
témoignage qu'il est ils vont voir si
les malades en l'avocate ça vraiment
c'est séverine toi tu coupes quoi alors
pour nous la ferons différé alors si tu
couvres c'est la réaction bien sûr tout
le temps
mais parce que c'est comme ça
le sujet et
alors non moi je suis choquée par ce
qu'elle a dit elle a pas dit c'est un
être humain elle a dit c'est quelqu'un
de très humain elle invite avec le
sourire aux lèvres que c'est
insupportable et moi pardon on parle de
la différence de traitement entre tpm
pays quotidien l'a effectivement le
chroniqueur la reprend bon c'est le mien
minimum mais il la laisse comme déroulé
son propos dudit bon c'est quand même
compliqué dire qu'il est très humain
vous cyril je suis désolé vous aurais
dit c'est insupportable de dire ça et
vous l'auriez pas laisser dérouler
pendant une minute pourquoi c'est
quelqu'un de très humain pourquoi on
doit avoir de l'empathie pour lui et
c'est donc là encore sur la différence
de traitement je trouve ça dégueulasse
pour tpm paix parce que certes il ya de
l'année qu'au début d'émission mais ils
interviewent elles sont menées de
manière sérieuse et à chaque fois qu'il
ya un dérapage vous recadrer les gens et
les chroniqueurs recadre les gens qui
dérape et là je trouve qu'elle a dérapé
et qu'on l'a laissé continuer son propos
pendant de trop longues secondes selon
moi on a le sentiment liberté est écoute
pas ouais mais pardon c'est moi il pose
des questions écrites aux brouteurs mais
qui n'écoutent pas les réponses parce
que s'il avait écouté la réponse il
aurait réagi mais ya julien qu'il s'agit
pas bien sûr chroniqueurs parfois vous
réagissez c'est moi qui ragent il arrive
aussi non là là là moi je vais vous dire
franchement il est reçu moi je trouvais
que c'était un super enfin couler on
peut pas parler de coût mais c'est pas
moi c'est un c'est intéressant voilà je
pense qu on leur aurait fait aussi des
interviews voilà après six mois c'est
surtout les réactions voilà ce qu'ont
nos rues je vous dis même l'avocate ça
aurait été utile ouais sur les réseaux
ç'aurait été un déferlement de redon
l'émission où le sait voilà on va pas se
raconter d'histoires donc voilà vous
pouvez tout vous raconter valérie c'est
pas ça oui moi j'ai rien contre le fait
qu'elle soit avocate et c'est vrai c'est
la démocratie il faut défendre les mecs
ont fait les plus grosses salles au prix
fort les défend par contre on se met à
la place des victimes une seconde si
elle veut faire l'avocate elle a qu'a
faire l'avocate de salah abdel ça au
tribunal oui moi je dis même pas son nom
en entier parce que j'arrive pas à
mettre un nom en entier sur une ordure
pareil kkk tirer comme ça délibérément
sur des gens qui demandaient qu'à être
heureux tu vois si cette fille là elle
avait quelqu'un dans sa famille qui
peut-être qu'il parlerait pas comme ça
mais moi je lui en veux beaucoup d'avoir
été sur quotidien pour fanfaronner pour
faire la belle en sortant des conneries
comme ça parce que ça c'est une connerie
pour français on rigolerait cyril moi je
dis les mots je m'en fous ces mémos
pardon si si ça choque les gens elle va
pour faire la belle pour dire ça à des
sables est très très humain où il est
très humain c'est la plus grosse des
saloperies moi ce mec là j'ai pu le voir
ni à la télé ni par et pour moi qu'ils
aillent mourir en prison et qui crèvent
là dedans et qui n'est lorsqu'ils en
sortent jamais qui pourrissent en prison
et les gens qui viennent sur les
plateaux pour expliquer que c'est
quelqu'un de très humain ces gens là qui
leur donne la parole aussi qui disent
que ces îles très humain on le laisse
parler ces gens là pour moi m'intéresse
pas moi ce monde là moi j'aurais préféré
que la police s'occupe du web moi je te
dis j'aurais préféré que la police
occupe de lui moi je veux pas qu'on
traîne sa pole ici il faut qu'ils se
fassent jugé benjamin et qui se passe
qui se passe mais qu'elle vienne pour
diriger dans sa psychologie générale de
2 romain et bas de la mocap dos des fans
tout le monde oui c'est un fait c'est le
rôle de l'avocat au tribunal n'ont
effectivement je comprends vraiment pas
et moi j'ai reçu vergès à la radio il ya
très longtemps verrai quand il parle de
de klaus barbie maintenant c'est un mec
qui m'inquiétait rail te dis en tant
qu'avocat jetterait défense d'un homme
qui avait fait des choses et pour moi
mais ils ont deux voies la rocca était
de le défendre mais il a jamais dit que
klaus barbie avait de l'humanité à
l'être humain jamais et c'est la grosse
différence parce que évidemment vers
j'étais un mec brillant et intelligent
et je pense que cette époque est là à
moins que moi vraiment raison pas
vraiment elle manque vraiment vraiment
allemand vraiment de métier parce que tu
ne peux pas dire à thé bio française
après ce qui s'est passé après ce qu'on
a vécu tous de dire que cet homme là est
très très loin soeur est une honte mais
absolument se déplacer de trucs oui
c'est d'autant plus choquant que en plus
de évidemment ce que ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher c'est son attitude au procès
il a été arrogant il de paix il a mené
tout le monde par le goût de et il était
vraiment si on n'était pas
content du sénat timothy dieuze odieux
donc en plus et elle elle continue à
dire elle est alliée tu es forcément
dire que c'est quelqu'un de très vieux
souvenez de ce qu'on avait vu son
attitude au procès ça j'aimerais bien
enfin servir ses desseins
culture à la cgil cause merci quoi